hello and welcome to Psy track your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel I am here
live after my holidays which were
amazing thank you very much and we are
going to be talking about the video I
dropped a little while ago now Harris
will be joining us in a minute but just
before we went live because we're very
professional on here he took a phone
call so as soon as he's back from
talking to a lady friend I'm certain
he'll be with us to discuss the news or
the rumor really that we've heard about
Brad Wright and the possibility of him
returning to Stargate so before we get
stuck in let's play the intro
[Music]
Matt's been working hard again and
creating us a bunch of new intros if you
haven't noticed by the way so
Psy Trek news first
we have um some very big news to hit you
with tomorrow
um about the soundtrack Channel and
things that we've been doing to try to
improve the
um Side Track experience for you lovely
people and we'll be dropping that
tomorrow when we are
um live with Matt and everybody
um let's give me one second we are live
right mm-hmm
yeah and we are going to be doing
um oh and the other big Side Track news
sorry we can we hit 25 000 subscribers
so not too shabby at all
um thank you everybody that really helps
the channel and
um supports us every day so you know
um 25 000 is amazing I mean I never
really thought we would hit anything
like that and
um I just think really it's a bit of
well in lots of ways it's a miracle that
we did
um 25 000 subscribers is you know a
decent number I I think I posted
something earlier in the week they said
basically like only like one one and a
half percent of YouTube channels ever
get over 10 000 subscribers so getting
25 000 and still growing is an absolute
really is amazing
so
we are going to have a chat about
this room about
um Brad Wright so well it's not really a
rumor in fact that I know for certain
from the sources that I've spoken to
that it is true
um in that I know that these people at
MGM
um mainly Michael Wright and Lindsey
Sloan are very interested in um bringing
Brad right back to the Stargate project
um if you haven't seen the video already
um it's already about 2 000 for you so
some of you I'm sure a lot of you will
have done
um basically
they're arguing these MGM Executives uh
Michael Wright is the head of MGM plus
and Lindsay Sloan is the head of
scripted material at MGM and Amazon her
is her um support for Brad right is
really important because Michael Wright
was there before Amazon bought MGM
there's an arm
there's an arm there's there's a boob
and there's Harris there's a person
hello and what's in trouble the lady
friend are you
before we get on there Harris have you
actually seen the video that I dropped
earlier today that we're talking about
yeah I did I was wide awake whenever it
aired and I watched it three minutes
after you dropped it
that's going to make the next hour or
next half an hour so a lot easier right
so
um I was just saying that basically
Michael Wright and Lindsey Sloan these
Executives at MGM are really supportive
I think the Lindsey Sloan news
and which is new we've never I've never
really talked about this one before
um but around November last year she
became the head of scripted material at
MGM and
um Amazon Studios
so I think she's really important
because she is actually an Amazon hire
yes Michael Wright was there before the
sale went through Michael Wright's been
the in charge of MGM Plus for two or
three years now Lindsay Sloan is a is an
Amazon girl okay
so I think that's really important that
she's actually now on board and and
making this argument with Michael Wright
that there there's been a lot of
infighting at MGM and Amazon for a while
about whether we should have a TV series
or a movie
um when should we do it how many
episodes should we have Brads do we not
this has been going on a while I mean
Jenny stivens talked about this a lot on
dial the game whatever as well there's a
lot of things fighting going on
um we believe Genesis Jennifer salkey
who's actually the head of prime is the
one that's going now we're doing a movie
and then she's the boss so
but I mean do you think it's important
that this
this isn't actually an Amazon employee
an Amazon hire I should say that is
actually now saying now come on let's
have Brad
yeah I think it is uh for for two
reasons obviously the Brad aspect of
things and and we'll we'll dive into
that because there's always good bad
things to talk about uh but
her being an Amazon hire Amazon employee
and not necessarily MGM
where it'd be cool if the MGM people
still had more say in Sway and and we're
able to kind of do the things they want
to do to a degree but it makes sense
Amazon being the parent company that
they're going to have more say and swag
I think her words gonna be more than
Michael's at the end of the day I guess
who I mean that's the person and
Jennifer salky and the rest of the team
at Amazon picked for this role but I
mean Michael Wright still got his job so
they obviously support him as well
they've got rid of a lot of other people
and like Pam Aberdeen people like this
they were gone you know straight away
virtually so
that's not contractual though is it I I
I'm just guessing I'm just
um the Palm Abdi and the other and and
her the her working partner that shot
over to Warner Brothers my understanding
was that they were the ones that were
saying that Amazon this is going to be
great for MGM Amazon gonna do this I'm
just gonna do that and then it became
very clear very quickly that Amazon I
weren't going to do it so they mutually
agreed they would leave
okay but Michael Wright has always
supported them he he was head of MGM MGM
plus and a few other things his role has
been pushed and been restricted a little
bit he's now just the head of MGM plus
um but he's still one of the main
figures at MGM
okay important
um we have another person joining us in
a second
I'm struggling a little bit and I've
been writing all day and um Harris is um
stoned and possibly drunk
um how are you Matt
I'm good
awful
what you sound
we know exactly what you're saying but
it sounds like you're saying it twice
it's like an immediate reverberation
it's kind of cool but for full sentences
it's a little much confusing yeah is
that better
absolutely not that's just your normal
voice now
that's what
the [__]
but right
um by the way guys get into the comments
I do want this to be interactive I want
your opinions so let's get on it Matt I
was just saying about um this Lindsay
Sloan who is actually in Amazon employee
she was hired by Amazon she's getting
behind Brad Wright and once Brad Wright
to return to this she thinks that's a
good idea do you think that is important
that it's not just people like Michael
Wright historical MGM I mean it would
have been it would have been Michael
right sorry that asked Brad to do the
script back in 2019 he was the boss back
there is this a new is this a new
um member of Amazon then completely new
she joined MGM and Amazon
um in November okay then yeah it's it's
definitely important having
um Michael Wright so I say all the time
is one thing because he's been there and
he's been fighting for it for years but
having someone new and fresh coming in
is it's basically us it's like it's like
a representation of Us coming into the
into the company and saying this is what
the fans want this is what yeah we want
so yeah very important very important I
think it's great somebody that doesn't
personally know Brad as well you think I
mean Michael Wright probably does I've
never asked Brad but I mean I could do
but um like I said they'd have had those
conversations so
um I have to I'm going to just very
quickly say
I want to be very very clear on this
because I've already had a couple of
comments Brad Wright has not been
approached as far as I know and as far
as any of my sources know
um and then I've asked them very
specifically there are no plans to
approach Brad right about this this is
purely these couple of Executives that
are MGM and Amazon making this argument
so all I'm saying is there are people at
MGM fighting for this to happen not
that there are any suggestions that it's
going to happen as far as we know
Jennifer saki wants to push forward with
a movie so that's going to be my first
question and I love you guys again to
get in the comments and and ask and and
really tell me what you think if they do
go abroad right can he do a movie
Executives would you trust him to do a
movie I should say
he's done movies before but he's better
at the TV show
just my first gut reactions no I I just
don't I I love the dude I just don't
know if a movie's his wheelhouse you
know
we're fantastic movies if they'd had the
screen time in the cinema
they're they're fantastic TV movies I
don't know if they would have done
cinematic
I I don't know I don't know I just I
don't I don't know they're perfect TV
movies
with those movies is you need to have
watched the entirety of zg1 in order to
appreciate them
um and he is good at making things that
link with
obviously the TV show because that is
his wheelhouse as you just put it
I don't know how my brain's still
functioning at the moment but it is and
I'm glad
we'll put it this way look Brad Wright
did a couple of movies but I would argue
they weren't really movies they were
long Stargate episodes that were
released as DVD movies yeah I mean in
every other respect they just look like
a Stargate episode
really there's no they didn't look like
a cinematic movie he didn't like up the
ante form uh which which part of me
appreciates because it still feels so
star date like it feels like the TV show
but also if you're gonna if you're
shooting for a cinematic kind of feel
you gotta up the ante to a degree
I disagree with that Target Continuum he
really up the hand too he literally I'm
not talking about plot wise I'm talking
about set design production quality
acting wise etc etc uh talk of Truth is
that is the end of season 10 of stagger
sg1 really I mean if you didn't know
that was released to the movie you
wouldn't know it
you just think it was a double episode
yeah
um so they they look it looks like it
looks exactly the same to me so I go
back to the original question if you're
an Amazon boss and it was your 100
million dollars would you give it Brad
right
not for a movie I would because I like
Brad
yeah I like Brad too and I would give
him his brother but I but if I was when
I was in Boston I hired Brad I don't
think I'd be an Amazon boss for very
long
okay well how about then you bring
Amazon sorry you bring Brad right on as
the showrunner for the series executive
producer for the movie and you do it
that way
say that one more time sorry I was
reading comments he would be showrunner
for the series so you would basically he
would be Alex kurtzman
all right for Stargate and I know that's
going to anger people
not the idiot Alex kurtzman but the Star
Trek's Alex Goodson so he would be the
executive juicer he would be the shower
and he would be the main man but he
wouldn't necessarily write everything he
wouldn't necessarily direct everything
um he would be
the captain of the ship but you would
for the movie you would bring in a
director you would potentially bring
another writers to support him you would
you know you would do something because
then if you bring another you bring in a
director that's got cinematic experience
but Brad right on his shoulder
you know directing things pushing it the
right direction because making sure it's
still Stargate will that work
is that that's not far from what they
would have done originally anyway he
didn't direct every single episode yeah
so it would yeah I mean it would work
I don't think it would be very far from
what they originally did
through Brad wouldn't it sort of thing
yeah yeah that's perfectly fine
I'm not as familiar with either Alex
Curtin kurtzman I guess but uh
Kevin feige is the example that comes in
my mind if he could be the [__] for
Stargate it would be beautiful
yeah that's more the Kevin fight would
be a better example of actually when it
works because
um with kurtzman
the big he's the big problem that a lot
of people feel anyway with Star Trek at
the moment that it's far too much of
Alex kurtzman's influence he wrote the
JJ Abrams movies
he seemed to want to bring a lot of that
influence into the series
um people hated it
they they didn't hire Terry matalis
instead of him but they kind of hired
him in his stead right in a way he came
in for season he wrote season two of
Picard or wrote bits of season two of
Picard and then he came in for season
three oh that's always done
oh before that he worked on like Deep
Space Nine and Enterprise I think as
well okay okay just because I did 12
Monkeys and he came back yeah okay
that's right
um but but yeah um one of the reasons
why Picard season three is the first
thing is show runs in the Star Trek
World okay that's kind of what I I
thought he had done like a multitude of
shows or seasons of shows like after
Kurt's been left or something like that
I don't know he wrote a fair bit of the
early likes I think I think it was
Enterprise he wrote a fair bit and he
like I said he's wrote an Enterprise I
remember when um metallis did an
interview recently you know and he said
like um he just finished 12 Monkeys and
he's saying his um sent an email to his
agency not Etc Star Trek
that's all I want to do just get me on
Star Trek I'll do anything
I like this comment yeah
would it be possible to revive SGU I
would say if Brad did come back it would
be a certainty that they would revive
SGU or at least have some sort of
conclusion
his plan was to to jump off that the
comment today I was reading while uh I
had to make you restate restate
everything uh was SGU was much more
cinematic and worked so well Mark said
that and
I I still think he'd have to SGU was
much more cinematic in in that way I
think every episode SGU was more
cinematic than even Stargate Continuum
honestly uh so I've it that's not the
quality of film I'd still be looking for
I'd still want a little bit more
especially if they're spending a bunch
of money on asingular like project
but hey he could do it maybe that makes
me oh that that shoots my pendulum a
little more Midway I guess
yeah I know what you mean
um just very quickly to say hello to
everybody in the chat hi Carrie hi
Jordan Ada hey Trek gay Don Christopher
hello everybody Davey I'm going to
mention something you mentioned earlier
in a minute Dave uh Michael hi everybody
in klopp
um United one I don't care that we might
have had a VR decision that went our way
so
control you
possibly
um but and then everybody else in the uh
I've just seen the track gate so yeah
I'm hoping for Brad no hard reboot dumb
and unnecessary
um yeah I mean that's talking about the
news that we had uh last week a couple
weeks ago now that um the director now
people got really upset about that
because this director must be an idiot
he was asking for a hard reboot listen
to what I said he didn't ask for a hard
reboot but apparently the director did
say if I want to do a hard reboot am I
allowed to which isn't the same thing
it's just sort of say look if I can't if
we can't figure out how to do this and
we don't get a good story is that an
option and I don't think that's
necessarily a bad thing I think that's
just laying all the cards on the table
seeing what's uh what's available and
what's not and and
um
yes make Brad the great overseer of all
of Stargate uh yes
this is what Curry wants to highlight
after everything is done after sg1 SG
and SGU I think we should know which
direction to go and do what he knows
that works there we go
I think that's very sensible at the end
of the day
one of one of our big concerns is that
anybody that comes in to Stargate has to
understand the franchise and that's one
of the big things again Star Trek that
people have said that people keep coming
in and writing Star Trek that don't seem
to have ever watched Star Trek before
they keep making loads of like Canon
mistakes and rewriting characters and
things and and they seem to have
forgotten
a lot of that you know if you're going
to write a Star Trek episode you should
know the Canon you should know Star Trek
that's one of the big fears for Stargate
is somebody going to come in and have a
rough idea what Stargate is and write
something they like
but with watching that they're going
well that's not right
have they forgotten that episode where
blah blah blah happened
you know there's a lot of episodes in
Stargate where they have like giant
freaking Concepts that just are like not
brushed aside but they do it quickly and
don't necessarily come back to it or
they mention it further on and that's
easy to gloss over
yeah
yeah it is
um
you're late so you know we're not
repeating ourselves so everyone
hello Papa um you can you can obviously
just go back and watch it from the
beginning
um but right so
one of the things entire 20 minutes
what's your 10 20 minutes again if
you're watching two or three times it's
good for um our numbers so I won't do
that so if um
right so one of the things actually was
one of our patreon members um I think it
was Dave now I'm not sure sure
um mentioned one of the ideas was that
when we were talking about back in 2020
when this all started
um the Brad Wright script was um being
tossed around Amazon and mmgm before
Amazon took over MGM
um and that Amazon kept coming back to
Sovereign
and then MGM showed at Amazon and Amazon
apparently kept sending it back saying
you can go big or do something bigger we
want we want you know we really want
something bigger
um
and that was one of the reasons
initially why we thought maybe Amazon
weren't going with Brad we then realized
there's a couple of business reasons and
because of this thing of them having to
have a partner
um like Warner Brothers something like
this that was that was more likely the
reason why they didn't want to they
needed somebody that was already sort of
connected to one of these Studios and so
it wasn't really possible but that's
changed now because they've got their
own Studios
um or starting to so I mean
does that make a difference then that
maybe I mean Dave's um point was that
now maybe the studios want to spend a
bit less money
maybe they're looking back on Brad's
initial idea thinking
that's more affordable
do you think that's a possibility
I was I was gonna counter question you
and say just from you saying the small
thing what would you prefer some big
giant bombastic thing that's just trying
to outdo everything else have some Sky
beam third act CGI crap Fest or would
you rather something smaller and more
intimate and I honestly feel like Brad
could bring the intimacy back and give
us something big enough to reintroduce
the characters that we love and we want
to see again
yeah
do it more intimately I guess and not
need to have sure there's gonna be CGI
there's gonna be all these other little
things but it doesn't need to be like
your third at crab festive CGI big
battle and Sky beam happens back here
because that's super freaking likely uh
if they want to make a big movie and try
to make it bombastic but
I think that would hurt a television
series for the movie it's gonna be a
relatively simple storyline isn't it
it's just it's two hours at most
I would pick I would put Brad doing a a
lower budget movie because he would do
it better than the higher budget movie
because they've gone on record before
saying that they went in the first
couple of seasons of sg1 they had
basically no money
yet made it work
he's if he's able to do it
do that for an entire season you can do
it for a movie for a couple it was like
two or three seasons they're basically
saying they have no money
yeah
and everything and 900 Grand episode
they have less than a million dollars an
episode which yeah it was nothing yeah
and then syndication happened and it all
kicked off and they actually got money
and then obviously a production value
went up but they did it without the
money to initially and it was a good
show so we can do it again
I think so and I think he's got an idea
of
like I've spoken to him a couple of
times and asked him what he thinks and I
know and I and I follow his Twitter and
I I see what he's he writes on Twitter
and he's always he he seemed to have a
logical thought of where Stargate is now
at least he thinks about it he still
thinks about Stargate today where would
it be now what makes sense but and one
of the things he sort of says was that
we were going to see a a a homemade
Stargate as it were so um we were
looking to try to understand the
technology more and build our own
Stargates I don't know why we would
because they were everywhere it seems
um logical step isn't it we made our own
ships we made
the kind of our own like weapons and
then the next logical step is well this
whole thing came about because of this
target let's just make our own because
would that be the next logical step
though yes because then they could
actually make a Target designed to like
get to Destiny
that draws less power they could they
can control the production they could
control how it works if they understand
that that's how they say like the
current Destiny I know I go on about
Destiny a lot but that's like roughly so
but that's that's a plot point
and it's something that he would
probably be thinking about yeah
um I I was always thinking was well they
could main Quan a bit bigger
to get stuff through maybe because they
start getting very big but I mean the
Ancients obviously didn't think it
needed to be bigger than that but well
you already did the stupid game and that
was that was good
yeah I I I I did like the idea of having
a Stargate that a spaceship could go
through I think that was amazing that
was one of the best things they ever did
okay
SGA does you one better that's why I
asked is it the next logical step
because at the end of SGA I know we've
discussed it before and we're like well
they say it doesn't work anymore but
would we still have you know where
they're at you know what exactly I'm
going to say somehow Drive Wormhole
drives wouldn't that be the next logical
step we've seen it work before
we have a Stargate
we've got extra ones if we need them
um
it never worked even for the Ancients
the Stars
the Wormhole Drive was abandoned by the
Ancients because it couldn't get the
damn thing to work it was like trying to
ride the back of an angry cat or
something it was just it was just got it
to work once it just about and um
it destroyed itself
um and they said they didn't know how to
fix it so it just burned out but it was
it was like well
trying to you know like the Tasmanian
devils
it was like trying to jump on the back
of him and going like go it was you know
a race sort of thing it was just like
well you know I guess I'm trying to
think of it coming from like it's a
government-run program and they watch
this
actually work
the government's going to try to
recreate it one way or another you know
yeah
um yeah uh that's I I'm sorry because
he's just jumped in this and yeah it was
it was a poor plot decision maybe but it
was a necessary one
um and then they destroyed it
immediately even though um Joseph malozi
said we were going to see it again
potentially in the movie The Instinct
distinct Extinction I couldn't say that
word for someone I want to say
instinction for some reason this isn't a
word
um it is now it's in the Star Trek
dictionary it's the essence and uh Maybe
yeah
um it was going to be about them going
back to Pegasus basically to sort out
The Wraith
um but we never got a resolution
Target revolutions was the third sg1
movie that was going to reveal the
Stargate program
that would have been amazing yes
we were going to say that wasn't the
name of the movie like yeah
yeah no it would have been um and then
um I think that might be kind of the
movie we end up getting
if Brad Wright
's it I would not be surprised at all if
that movie idea is very similar to the
plot for the pilot episodes that he
wrote already
just had a thought as well so you
mentioned Brad has been thinking about
this
for the last 12 years
yeah right
one of the biggest issues we've got is
there's been
12 13. however long it's been nearly 15
years without Stargate but in his mind
it's carried on and he's thought about
where they are what they've done
so he knows exactly how to start the
movie where they would be like
politically technologically all this
kind of stuff and logically logically as
well that's the thing he said yeah makes
no sense that it would still be a secret
and and if you think about it we're
going around the planet giving like
macro degenerators to people but people
on our own Planet uh you know haven't
gone through energy crises makes no
sense it's not logical
um
I was typing
um sorry my my dinner is very very soon
so I'm just waiting for the text to say
it's fine that you can go as soon as you
need to but but yeah
um
one of the other comments that we've had
on the video I did earlier was why would
we want Brad Wright to come back when
he's the one that killed the franchise
in the first place
did he kill the franchise or did mgm's
bookkeep and kill the franchise
uh that that's what 100 I would argue
whether you love or hate Target Universe
it was getting a lot better
and I I was enjoying I I don't like
Stargate Universe I think it was boring
but it was getting better and how many
how many I keep saying this how many
Sci-Fi series have we seen that the
first season and maybe even the second
season aren't very good but go on to
become the greatest the first season of
Stargate sg1 wasn't very good except for
a couple of brilliant episodes
first season of star second the Next
Generation which is now considered one
of the greatest Star Trek episodes the
last 30 series the last 30 years sci-fi
series in the last 30 years was awful
um but it went on to be brilliant
um yeah yeah there's plenty of TV shows
not just sci-fi that's there's good
examples of that Breaking Bad wasn't
good until
season three
I mean it was it was a very good show
but it was very boring
brilliantly and then it got good and it
started building and then I think yeah
it's always sunny in Parks and
Recreation come to mind with that those
first seasons were
all right
in Philadelphia I keep meaning I I
always want to watch it because I see
clips of it from now I went to watch the
first first episode and because it was
like 20 years ago I'm looking at going I
don't know any of these characters
this isn't funny
they filmed it for like 75 bucks that
was literally like the budget for the
first episode and now they're the most I
think they they get the biggest budget
of like any 20 minutes that come on air
right now which you know after 16 years
why not but
I will have I will hear nothing bad said
about Joseph malozi
because people saw the archived with
them and um
kill the franchise not a clue
um but um
was Atlantis for the very for the last
two seasons
yeah and he wasn't he was a a consultant
in SGU wasn't he I believe he was
involved in su1 and SGU but he show ran
SGA for the last two seasons Brad Wright
gave up the Reigns and gave it to him
and I would argue the final seasons of
SG stagger Atlantis were the best
seasons I was just about to say that
same thing I was like I think those
might be my two favorite Seasons he
wrote some of the best episodes of SGA
um the one whether you know he says um
you shot me yeah I'm sorry Rodney they
shot you because no you shot me
for everybody I'm sure Melissa wrote
that I think he sees me too isn't it
season yeah end of season two starts
yeah it's where rodents in it so it's at
least yeah yeah I was so good I'd
forgotten that Roland isn't join it
until like two or three years
what's his name Aiden Aiden Ford yeah
just trying to get him through the first
season he's a good character to be fair
in the end but he was so boring when he
was just a member of SGA the actors got
the coolest name ever too I can't think
of it
[Music]
so cool
um but but yeah I mean I I just thought
it was great so um
what else we're going to talk about
it's just a platform power comment I'm
sorry
no Brad right you want Kathleen Kennedy
and no I just think Jennifer salkey
should do it so let's just get her in
charge
um is is uh is it Lindsay Sloan is that
the right name uh yeah is she a sulky
hire
yes okay okay is she sulky is she
soaking yeah
see when she got the job she was like
um I applied but I didn't really want it
I don't know why I applied
you need to get Brad back
my mom told me to
I need a new job
I I would agree yeah but yeah that's I
think that's why it's important that
she's one of the names I believe there
are other people as well that are
fighting for this but these are the
names that the sources said to me the
reason why this has come about it was
the apparently there was a mink in about
three weeks ago and apparently Michael
Wright got very animated as he
apparently tends to do
um but Lindsay Sloan and this was the
first time the source I was speaking to
actually witnessed it themselves the
Lindsay was important in the whole way
um and but apparently some of the
meetings about mgm's Direction over the
next five years do get quite animated
and apparently a lot of the time it's
Michael Wright that makes them quite
animated
so um I have a roommate this is a
distinctly rumor that we have a meeting
with Jennifer salty um this is and when
he came back in he was heard saying
several exclusives and then kicked a bin
across the office
but I don't know if that's true or not
but it's it would be funny if it was
um entertain in one way or another
I never find out whether it was true or
not medical purposes that is just a
rumor this is a distinctly rumor and
distinctly
um probably not true so let's just go
with that's not true um but if it was
funny
um
so yeah I just wonder where does this
leave things like Mark Ferguson if
if they were to go with Brad right
I don't think it kicks him out
completely you can still
be the showrunner you could yeah he
could still be involved
if they bring Brad back doesn't mean
Brad's going to be there forever Brad's
old Brad's in his 70s
he's gonna he's gonna retire at some
point
maybe it will be like
Brad and his apprentice and The
Apprentice is
um
[__] what's his name mark Fergus yeah
and then it's going to be like in his
will I give Stargate to Mark Fergus or
whatever it's like George Lucas Dave
filoni like just just we need a felony
for Stargate please
bring him Nathan Philly and do a load of
hero ship characters based on you know
very character-driven show call it
Firefly great
um
that kind of start getting it
um so
yeah I I don't think that I don't think
that's right okay he's in his 60s but
still that's near nearly retirement age
yeah
um well I don't think Brad right has any
intention to retiring anytime soon
um but I I know where you're coming from
I just think that look Brad Wright could
be the showrunner he could write the odd
episode here and there mark Ferguson
hawkosby didn't
um show run
um the expanse it was at Shankar oh
Shankar yeah they're not show running
the
um series they're doing with Amazon now
um God of War they're not sure again
they're developing it developing seems
to be their bag now the rumor we heard
was that Mark Fergus wants to step up he
wants Stargate to be his baby
but
he's got lots of other projects and
penguin and Park have got lots of other
projects maybe Amazon would go like come
on now this is we this is really a big
deal
we want someone else to come in and show
run
you know you do what you do you know you
do what you do great we're gonna you
know write loads of the episodes we're
gonna bring another Brad rice gonna work
with you
I I just wonder if that's the way and To
Me Brad Wright is is such an inclusive
person he never says if you say Brad
Wright the creator of Stargate he will
be the first one to go no I wasn't
I was the co-creator of Stargate and
there was lots of other people involved
Robert Cooper did just as much as I did
um you know what I mean um and look at
malosi look at everyone
so
I I think if you're going to bring in
Brad Wright and you wanted somebody that
was inclusive
I'm absolutely certain it could work
with somebody like Mark Fergus
yeah yeah but if if Burgers comes in and
either show runs or develops
does that automatically obviously we
don't know we're just speculating but do
you think that would
put him in a position for the movie or
would they still hire a whole separate
director for that or and maybe Fergus
would help develop that or what I guess
Focus has done movies before I don't
think I would have any problem with him
coming in writing the script working
with another director working with
whatever I don't see that'd be a problem
you know the director that comes to mind
we shouldn't say it but
there's a couple
there's the one that I want that I like
you know I'm thinking well later
okay well we know there's a few names
knocking around and that we've had
rumors about so
but no let's um let's not worry too much
about that yes all right
um
we'll talk about after the streaming but
uh but yeah uh yeah let's see what
happens but but yeah whoever that comes
in obvious isn't going to direct anyway
so they're going to bring in a director
so
um Brad Wright's been a bit directive I
don't think you direct promotional
picture obviously
Amanda Tapping does some directing and
man's tapping does and that would be a
step up for her but why not the big
issue then that we were talking about
um in the video earlier was that
there is a rings of power problem for
um Amazon that they've got a reputation
now of making some TV shows that haven't
been great and let down fans and there
was a lot of negativity about the rings
of power six months before it ever came
out we've discussed this loads of times
is this a no-brainer because that's what
that's what makes me Michael Wright and
Lindsey Sloane seem to be arguing this
is a no-brainer
make the phone call
is it as easy as that
you'd think so I mean why wouldn't you I
don't think anyone was pining for a Lord
of the Rings TV series
a prequel for that matter I don't think
anyone was shouting in the streets or on
online that we want this
I might be wrong I'm not part of that
Community but I don't remember I've
never seen anything like that online
there is a massive
well we we are we are
the massive Community obviously there's
other people have done us but
who are pining for this show it is a
no-brainer there were so many people out
there people who don't necessarily
interact with with us online either not
just us but you know it's a Stargate
fandom uh-huh
when they do these polls online and they
say oh there's like a million people
interested there are there are
significantly more people as well who
don't participate in those polls there
is a massive audience for Stargate
yeah as we've seen sleeping giant sci-fi
four million views or something this
Channel's got
largely attributed to the fact that
Stargate is something we talk about
yeah it's not an accident it's it's
they're people Sarah makes a brilliant
point there that some of the best
Jonathan some of the best Star Trek
episodes of late and one of the big
names behind why they think Picard
season 3 did so well is because Jonathan
Frakes was the director somebody that
loved the franchise really understands
what Star Trek is is Amanda Tapping our
Jonathan Frakes
she could be yeah
director a very good producer a very
good executive producer she knows how
the industry Works in front and behind
the camera
she really could be our
particularly have a beard though
which is unfortunate
um but um and but I mean she if she if
she had help as well if they brought in
people to support her which they do
sometimes to these things yeah that
knows what they're doing you know what I
mean
foreign
probably wouldn't be the best idea but
if she was tapped to do the film as well
she'd probably be good for a more
intimate smaller film and it'd be good
just to get your immediate Stargate fan
base back through those four million
views you were just saying plus every
other Stargate fandom Channel anywhere
all of their views are immediately going
to the movie theater for that
immediately going into the TV series so
those eyeballs will be there
if you
tapped Amanda are you Amanda Tapping
that sounds very rude
I I need an alliteration like if a
woodchuck could chuck wood with this uh
tapping if you try to tap Amanda Tapping
in any way I'm pretty sure she could
knock you out
so um I think she could handle herself I
think
yeah I think she'd like us as well
um I mean yeah I I I I think it would be
you know brain I just think
um Amazon have been so burned by the
rings of power which whether you like
the show or not has had a lot of
negativity thrown at it and if and it
harmed it it hurt it
um
said how much they spent on that on that
TV series
a billion dollars
no one would have been the wiser people
might people might have enjoyed it and
then
it's because there's an expectation when
there's a billion dollars
obviously there's the whole woke thing
as well but we will ignore that there is
going to be an expectation anyway I
think they had to release the number
probably if they could have avoided
talking about it they probably would
have I bet you the Tolkien estate was
like
because they they I mean they did they
were literally like we just took 1.1 1.2
billion dollars for this one series
now we're gonna sell off for 750 million
dollars because this is how much we're
valued and you know they they use that
as a business deal uh so it was almost
just screwed up for the Tolkien estate
at Amazon honestly I know that's
probably sacrilegious to say for a lot
of Tolkien folk but as a publication
company as well Amazon I don't think
could hide a billion dollars yeah they
couldn't do they just had to front it
but I know what you mean I think that
was the biggest problem they had was the
budget and people but how many times did
people go billion dollars a billion
dollars like it matters
and what it is and money I suppose
because it's so many we've given Amazon
but you know what I mean it's not our
money so um you you mainly think about
something while we were tapping Amanda
Tapping tap whatever that whatever
alliteration came up with uh
oh
they do hire someone that's not as
if this is like someone stepping up kind
of thing like oh give them the new
series like Amanda Tapping like put her
step her up to the uh plate for this
obviously she's a little more tried and
true she's produced her own television
series she's done a few different things
like that
but you just said rings of power those
two guys that wrote that obviously we
already have riders that will probably
be on the ball kind of deal they're
they're
seasoned veterans in the writing world
uh much less so than the two guys that
wrote rings of power if but if if I
guess Stargate goes the route of like
we're going to give someone a chance on
this
yeah
do you think that's more likely that
we're going to have a not as good
product would you rather have that
seasoned showrunner even you could say
that about Mark Fergus too uh because he
hasn't technically show ran would it be
better for him just to stay as a
developer and not actually show run if
and say hey if you really want this to
be your baby
work up work up to it you know uh set
yourself financially up for the baby
first I don't know I mean normally
showrun is direct or something I mean
Kevin Faye though he was you know he's
never he's never written anything or
directed anything as far as I know and
it's one of the best showrunners you
could argue he's let the rains go in the
last couple of years but he's one of
those technically never show ran either
no you know it's just he is the captain
of the ship that when he's the he's the
manager sort of thing that runs and runs
everything but yeah I know what you mean
you never get maybe get involved and
actually day-to-day stuff you just make
sure everyone's going the right
direction Brad would be far more
creative if that was the way things went
um
yeah uh yeah I mean Dave David said
they'll get someone who's never done a
single episode of the franchise but
promises to honor the Legacy
I I suspect David hood is possibly a
Star Trek fan
um because that's our Star Trek fans
feel
um you know last uh
anyway
um Dave Bradley Bradley
involved Su mostly disliked seu just by
hope they give the winning formula to
sg1s yeah yeah we need some fun back
into it uh who's we
yeah yeah I know you liked SGU but out
of the three
what's your favorite
actually save that for tomorrow because
that's tomorrow's conversation you're
thinking about it I might be wearing a
different color hoodie tomorrow yeah
well tomorrow's Live Chat is all about
um
which is the best Stargate franchise
because I did a video about it and I've
told you my opinion and we'll see but
guys
I know Matthew needs to eat
Harrison needs to sleep and um I'm on my
own this evening isn't it like 7 A.M for
you
it's 10 48.
oh okay he hasn't slept do you remember
have you not gone to sleep yet
no
I have I got a story for you after we
get we leave this
we'll we'll go to be young again
does it involved the um yes yes yes it
does
not be watching
um but yes I should subscribe
I do my due diligence good if if I got
past 11 o'clock at night I'd be asleep I
would be the guy in the corner of the
nightclub uh
a nightclub and he's he's he meets a
woman and he goes to subscribe to
soundtrack
uh clubs in Sidetrack shirts
I wish I could tell you no God no we're
not telling you dark times I'm not
letting you so yeah
that guys thanks for joining us on this
um impromptu live show like I said we
have some very interesting Side Track
news but we're going to tell you
tomorrow
and thank you again so much for allowing
us to hit the 25
000 Mark
um I stayed up half the night waiting
for I was watching the subscribers click
on my holidays
um but it was um it was it was very
exciting to hit 25k I'm a little bit
concerned that we're halfway through
fifty thousand
and I have to get it back to at that
point
um but you know I understand
[Music]
all right I'm thinking on my shoulder
but we'll we'll see
um and then somebody else has said what
are you gonna do at 100 000 and I'm
gonna do a strip show no not really
[Music]
um
you could do a funny Sidetrack racy
calendar for a hundred thousand
and then you'd have another merchandise
product but
we'll all have to be in it though okay
as long as I don't have to be slave
layer I'm good you I I want to say
storms to take part in that right
I'll just pay you no you do she told uh
um
I forgot what we decided I was
here I can't remember why but uh
um I don't remember I can't remember the
the name because it's a long funny name
uh he's got his actual name inside of it
but it's like a long elongated name uh
what was it you're the badger Jamie's
the Gopher stormy is the wise old Alan
was I was a fox
foxy Fox yeah I don't know why I'm about
to I don't even know who said it who who
called us these things
are back
who was it I don't remember the guy's
name but he has his name inside of like
it's like v d it's like the
Eric Jones or something like that you
know oh yeah these messages since he's
the guy that keeps trying to get himself
banned because when you're gonna ban me
you haven't done anything and then we
did and we it went too long or whatever
yeah I timed him out and accidentally
banned him for the entire thing yeah
yeah yeah it was Lee Wilcox you're right
and his name was in the long big thing
yes and he decided we were all well
Harry's got a really good memory
thank you
um you must live stream and sing the
praise of the new Star Wars Trilogy of
openly
oh do you mean the last Star Wars
trilogy
um I was going to say I hope and we
we've hit 100 000 maybe before another
Star Wars Trilogy comes out but um we'll
see I almost pressed leave studio in
that comment yeah so uh no basically I
didn't hate the Star Wars trilogy but
I'm not a big Star Wars fan so I'm
watching it just going oh that's funny
whereas everyone else's they're gone
that shouldn't happen we'll go to the
dark side I do like Star Wars but I'm
not a massive Star Wars fan either I
enjoyed the LA the last three movies
but but because I'm a slight a slightly
above average I guess I could see the
glaring problems with it but I'm like I
don't care
brain wants some star guests we are
trying we might have a couple
so what wait am I not good enough
never been recognized in public so I
don't count
um in New York I I once had so there's
an event called Summer in the city
so back when I was YouTuber back in the
day right I had this is not a lie
a load of people with me and we were all
going down the road and they were
chanting Matt Dean beauty queen Matt
Dean Beauty green
highlighted my career
I love it
instead of a can we call you the badger
beauty queen now
yeah I mean I had more hair there so I
was a beauty queen but
I was once chased by many policemen
shouting and put your clothes back on
does that count
yeah yeah that's very govery yeah they
didn't recognize me and such because I
was running away but I'm pretty sure
they would recognize me if they met me
again
so
if they saw me from behind naked that's
fast back then anyway
I love that you said that as I typed out
the word Sandy Cheeks
I wasn't Sandy it was shiny I was I was
responding to somebody named Sandy
Cheeks in the chat
if the shoe fits uh anyway I was very
drunk and um fast so got away with it
anyway
guys thank you so much for um Coming and
having a chat with us about that I
thought it was we'll try to do this a
bit more often when something dropped
like this we'll do a video that people
can watch but then we'll talk about it
afterwards where we can because I think
it's interesting
um we will see you tomorrow when we're
doing the is SGA the best of the
Stargates and we'll begin that argument
for fun so
um thank you so much guys everyone's
saying bye now bye now bye-bye
got it
bye
[Music]